how do you communicate the realities of
climate change without people switching
off though well xayah there's a really
interesting stat that a cake was
apparently mentioned 10 times more than
climate change on uk tv shows in 2020 so
what's your view is climate change taken
seriously enough is the right message
getting out there whether it's factual
programs or fictional ones
well i think that there are several
difficulties that science communicators
and scientists have faced and one of
them does have to do with the media i
know that stat from vast bafta that came
out which is quite frightening that cake
gets more coverage but the thing is we
have to think we're facing a code red
climate emergency and if you look around
there's only one daily climate show on
earth and we happen to be on it right
now so we need a lot more coverage
that's for sure the other thing though
that scientists have faced is that big
oil and lobby groups and think tanks
have actively interfered in climate
science for years just like big tobacco
and so they've been injecting doubt so
scientists have spent you know 20 30
years fighting this disinformation when
they could have been putting across
clear science a couple other points
though is that scientists themselves can
improve in terms of using less
dense language and also not using such
big numbers human beings suffer from
what's known as scale blindness so if i
start saying things like you know we've
lost 46 million
acres of trees every year 29 trillion in
national debt 1 600 billion in weapons
and arms people's eyes glaze over you've
probably heard the saying that one death
is a tragedy and 1 million is a
statistic so it's very important that we
are concise with our language and also
tell stories that stick to the facts but
are also a little bit more personal
because that reaches people and has more
impact
yeah and tom do you agree with that and
also what about tone as well because
do you think that
scaring people
is effective you know people kind of get
the severity of the problem or do you
think people switch off i mean how do
you pitch the tone when you're talking
about climate change
well i mean scaring people has a role
right i mean in terms of waking up and
being aware of the situation that we're
facing and that's often what the school
strikers are saying to us is we need to
tell the truth we need to be honest
about the situation that we're facing
but it it runs out of road after a while
i mean part of the issue that we face at
the moment is that the issue is so large
as was explained by zia and the and the
solutions that each of us can put into
place are so small in compensating
commensurate with the size of the
problem so as a result of that you get
to a situation where everything that you
do feels futile i also think i mean i
think it's great that we have this daily
climate show and i hope to see more of
it i also think this needs to be baked
into all kinds of other programming that
happens around the world i mean the fact
that cake is mentioned so many times on
british television i had no idea there
are ways in which climate change
intersects with cakes right and we
should actually be finding other
platforms and interests and ways in
which people are already talking about
issues that they're that they're
concerned about and demonstrating how
that intersects with climate it doesn't
have to be a specifically climate
focused piece to bring in the fact that
climate is going to touch that issue too
well we are out of time but thank you
both for picking up the daily climate
show we we didn't insist on it but we
appreciate it thank you uh tom rivet
connect xayah exayatong always good to
see you though thanks very much indeed